depuis le début de la journée les prises
de parole se multiplient pour condamner
l'offensive russe sur l'ukraine pour
teen poutine importe ainsi la souffrance
et la destruction à ses voisins directs
il a décidé de porter la teinte la plus
grave à la paix à la stabilité dans
notre europe
cette entreprise hideuse et barbare
degré dit mir poutine doit se solder par
un échec pour s'accorder sur les
réponses à apporter les initiatives
occidentales sont nombreuses réunions
des dirigeants du g7 dans l'après-midi
conseil européen dans la soirée pour
valider un paquet de sanctions massives
contre la russie le président du conseil
charles michel a par ailleurs appelé la
biélorussie allié de moscou à ne pas
prendre part à l'offensive vendredi
c'est un sommet virtuel de l'otan qui
doit avoir lieu alors que l'alliance
atlantique est d'ores et déjà en état d'
alerte
nous avons une centaine d'avions de
chasse en alerte dans le ciel pour
protéger notre espace aérien et plus de
120 bateaux en mer du grand nord à la
mer méditerranée
à new york le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu se réunira de nouveau dans la
soirée mais l'adoption d'une résolution
condamnant l'entrée en guerre de la
russie est totalement improbable
l'unanimité étant requise
moscou qui occupe actuellement la
présidence tournante du conseil il
mettra forcément son veto la question du
positionnement de la chine reste
cruciale alors que pékin disait encore
dans la matinée comprendre les
préoccupations sécuritaires du kremlin